More
holy bright
Hey guys, welcome back to the workshop
We've got another fun experiment using glow sticks today
And it involves combining the glow stick fluid with this decorative fountain it might not be too hard to guess
But we're gonna see if we can extract enough glow fluid to put it into this fountain and actually have its cycle with glowing blue
Liquid so we have a whole ton of these glow sticks
We're gonna crack them open separate the two fluids within and then we'll put those into the fountain
I'm gonna try and separate it so one of them is in the base and the other one is in the little
Dishes up above so that as the fountain starts running it starts activating the glow. Hopefully we can get that to work
I think it would look really cool if it does
We've got a bunch of rocks right here
And these are actually what I'm going to put down in the base of this fountain
This base is actually what holds normally water in our case glow fluid
But it's pretty big and empty and that would use up a lot of glow sticks, and we already have a ton
But I wanted to cut down on the number that we would need so I'm gonna use these rocks to sort of fill the empty
Spaces of this base, so there's still enough fluid to cycle, but not so much that we're just wasting glow sticks
I also have these little rocks in a bag those are going to be a decorative element on top look
It's scattered all around the base
And I'm hoping it will help the fluid diffuse and the glow will like
Flow in between the rocks and make it look even cooler. Let's give it a shot
Let's start cutting open a whole bunch of glow sticks load our rocks into our fountain
Pour our glow fluid into the fountain and hopefully get a bright
Cascading glowing effect as we run the fluid through this fountain this should look really sweet
Alright that looks like it still goes on still in place our pump is still down inside the fountain
But we have displaced a lot of the volume, so we shouldn't need quite as much blow fluid however
I still believe it's going to take three or four cups of liquid to make this fountain be able to run
Now we get to cut these all open drain the fluid and hopefully have enough
To get our fountain working now. We've seen the reaction when we crack one of these glow sticks
But what exactly is going on inside there are four main chemicals that help create this
Reaction over ninety percent of what's inside the glowsticks is a chemical called diethyl phthalate
The dimethyl palyed is mostly a stabilizer
That's used to help keep the other chemicals from going bad while sitting around in the glowstick the two primary
chemicals that are reacting with each other to create the glowing effect are hydrogen peroxide and
tert-butyl alcohol the glowsticks will also contain a fluorescent
Dye, and there are a variety of chemicals that can be used depending on what color is desired (blue in this case)
We have now harvested the fluid out of about 50 glow sticks
That's what these four cupfuls of liquid are and now we have to get the fluid out of these glass pieces as well
We'll put those in a separate container so that they won't combine until they are running in the fountain
These are glass which I have to break to get the fluid out, so I'm trying to cover them
Crack them over the trashcan so we don't have little bits of glass that go everywhere
That one exploded most of them pop open that one exploded open
At this point we've got four clear plastic cup full of one fluid and
About one and a half of these squeeze bottles of the inside fluid this should be the stuff that adds the dye and this is
The activator where you can see the color showing up in the dye if we hit it with a black light
Which it doesn't really do much to the activator at this point
It's time to take our activator fluid and put it in the base of the fountain and see if it looks like we're going to
Have enough to run this sucker
Here goes...
Think we are just there once we add the colored dye into the top bowls. I think we shouldn't have any problems with this
Now let's add some pebbles down around the base
This fountain actually doesn't drain out of this bottom bolt the bottom bowl is plugged up by what's actually an LED and
We'll be adding a little bit of additional light not that we should probably need it
But it should spill up and over the edge and sort of around these pebbles
Which is why I'm hoping. They'll make it look extra good
There is a chance that because of the different ratio
I've got going with tons of activator and only a little bit of dye
It's not gonna be super bright at first, but as soon as it starts moving
I'll probably add a little bit more of the dye fluid into the fountain so it all gets going in circulation
Hopefully it worked pretty well. This is an experiment. I haven't done this before
Here we go three two one
Yeah, all that looks super good
Amazing Oh
Fantastic it's such good color in there
This is looking really sweet just to see what happens let's take some magenta colored dye and pour that into the top
Change it a little bit we have a little bit of a purple fluid flowing down now
It's not extreme, but it was only one magenta compared to like fifty blue. That's pretty neat
There is one more thing that I do want to try
We've seen what happens if we mix a little bit of dish soap
In with our Glo fluid and the result is that it starts glowing a lot more brightly just not for very long
so I'm going to try adding some into here and see what happens it might not mix very well until it gets down and
Pulled into the pump a little bit
But hopefully we can get a fountain that starts flowing a lot brighter
It's definitely brighter down here than it was up there. Oh, I think it's now getting pulled through
Looks to me like we're getting more brightness out of this thing. I don't have a good sense of how much to add really
This is a lot more fluid than just from one glow stick, but if you add too much
It will kill it a little bit of a gamble here
But I definitely think we saw an increase in the brightness a little whirlpool
We're a small spot bubbles is just circling in one spot. It's kind of funny
That doesn't look like a health potion from a video game. I don't know what does
Maybe that just means this is like a fountain of youth
You add more soap see if we can actually just kill it with all the soap
Seems to be able to handle a fair bit of soap, it's not dying
Maybe it is that does look a little dimmer. I think it's gone down
Lose really smoothly. I think part of the point of these fountains with water is that you get the nice trickling noises
But because this fluid is more oily and viscous. It doesn't really make trickling sounds you can hear the pump running
Near the pump running a lot right now
Which means I might have made the pump angry by filling it with thick things like oily glow fluid and soap
And we now have some bubbles
Starting to form at the top here and our pump is barely trickling
So I'm gonna say I've made our pump angry and unplug it now
The glow fountain works entertainingly well we got some really cool bright colors that looked like something straight out of the movie Avatar
I think I really like to look and then of course adding soap it did get a lot brighter
And then I kept adding soap and now as you can see there's like nothing left. It's just drained out completely
It's very entertaining to watch the dynamic between the soap and the glow fluid
We want to hear your ideas for what else we should do with this glow fluid because it looks really cool
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you aren't a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to check it out again click up here
At the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should be watching next
That's it for now.
Have fun.
Be safe and
see you tomorrow.